I'm making great films in any genre
requires great storytelling compelling
characters and certainly connecting with
the audience despite the fact that
documentaries are based on real life in
the hands of a talented filmmaker the
form could be as diverse as any other
and our nominees tonight our absolute
proof of that we're honored to present
the gold silver and bronze prizes for
documentary films from the 237
documentary entries this year the
winning films are boxy adoro by May
Meg's maker from Stanford University in
California tells the story of a woman
she followed her dream and defied Fidel
Castro's ban on female boxing to become
Cuba's first female boxer I married my
family's killer by Emory Emily Cassie
from Brown University in Rhode Island
following the 1994 Rwanda genocide
intermarriage brought two former war
enemies together and looking at the
stars by alessandra Peralta from the
University of Southern California which
tells the inspiring story of young women
in Brazil pursuing their dream in the
world's only ballet school for the blind